dealing with sexuality in a song well as
you said when you were first starting
out were there people that told you
don't do to too much of that it's
alienating you may sort of divide the
audience but now all these years later
in 2016 it's really open there is no I
don't know anybody who would judge a
song simply based on the sexuality of
the singer or the sexuality of the
lyrics or whatever it is do you feel
that it's kind of like an open world now
that you are cool to do anything like
that explore any parts of yourselves in
music I definitely feel were lucky
because of the path we chose early on in
our career I never felt restricted no
one ever sat us down to tell us how to
be or what to write but we took our cues
from society and the people around us so
you know we knew early on that our best
chance at success was not to be too much
like this band you know we openly spoke
about writing songs that we thought were
universal and that you could relate to
and you could relate to and you could
relate to and I think that absolutely
like you said things have changed and
it's a little easier to just come right
out and just say something in a song in
a way we wouldn't have ten years ago and
there's a lot of gender and sexuality
being explored in music there's a
fluidity to like both those things and
in the mainstream right now and there's
been massive change and legislation that
has obviously made it a lot safer and
easier and we are in a very creative and
artistic industry so people have always
embraced us but we've don't confuse that
there's also it's safe for us here but
we're also conscious of the fact that
like when we're traveling overseas and
internationally that the politics are
different everywhere we go so there's
still our objective is still to reach as
many people as we can so we're still
making sure our message is deep and
thoughtful but also can still reach
everyone like I don't want anyone
slamming the door in our face what I
want is for you to invite me to the
party
and then when I get to the party I want
you to dance I'm gonna want to tell you
this really important thing that maybe I
wouldn't gotten in the door if I told
you before I bother